So this lesson we're going to
go through an exercise.
Imagine you had to prepare an analysis
model of the external behavior of this
clock radio using state charts.
What steps would you take to do this?
Because we are concerned
here with modeling behavior,
one natural way to get started is with
usage scenarios, also called use cases.
A use case is a sequence of steps,
each involving an actor performing
an action, possibly on an object.
Clearly any model of behavior of the
clock radio must indicate how each of
the use cases is realized.
See if you can come up with three
typical use cases for the clock radio.
>> Okay.
So the first use case I can think of
is that the user is setting the time for
one of the three different modes.
Whether that's the display time or
the time we want the alarm to go off.
There's a third time but with each of
those, I guess there's a separate use
case but we'll just say setting
the time is use case one.
>> Okay, so, Jared is right
that each one of those would be a
separate use case and now we're picking
the one about just setting the time
of day that's visible on the display.
>> And then for use case number
two we could change the frequency
of the radio so we may be in AM mode and
changing the frequency,
or in FM mode and
changing the frequency.
>> So regardless of the mode, we're
changing what station is coming in.
>> Right, so we're going to be
twisting that knob to change it.
>> On the side.
Okay.
And then for a third use case, let's
say the user presses the snooze button,
the alarm's going off and
they want to sleep a little bit longer.
>> Okay.
Clearly there are lots of other ones,
like just listening to the radio,
turning it on and just listening to it,
or getting shocked out of
bed by the beeper going off.
Lots of possibilities here and
ultimately, our state and
chart model needs to be able to cover
all the cases that might arise,
including error cases,
including situations where what you had
hoped to happen doesn't happen and the
radio has to respond in that situation.